buongiorno brugman numero non sto
tenendo il conto costa bottano nuova
puntata le macchine in realtà non
lasciata aperta quindi a casa mi ha
veramente la polvere in due secondi sul
piumone e le federe senza kobe letto
perché mi sono reso conto stamattina
prendendo una bella boccata d'aria che
stavo in un porcile
ho sentito cadaveri in avanzato stato di
putrefazione profumare meglio quindi
stamattina ho una giornata di pulizia
più divertente
ho già diviso per terra e colorati i
bianchi e queste sono tutte coperte
perché questo problema con le lenzuola
praticamente interessantissimo e so che
mi interessa essendo così grandi mi
scoccia lavarle perché poi non so
piegarli quando inizia a piegare le
coperte che sono bagnate e come se
spazzasse casa con un mocio umido alla
fine lo faccio mai nulla ma oggi mi sa
che arrivato il momento di una mossa la
prima però deve per forza essere
colorati perché sto senza mutande too
much information dovremmo riempire
questa giornata in qualche modo
o vi dico non possiamo girare proprio
qualsiasi cosa io faccia dai per favore
fammi passare bagnato non è che era
chiuso gianmarco momento ha fatto rimane
paravano buche dove ci abbiamo cose da
fare con che buono sta ammorbidente si
delizioso
sì anche perché sono arrivate né coda
leggono e volevo far proporre tipo una
specie di sfida uno contro uno un team
che deve montare da me no occhio i
perizomi in stand di linea molta
attenzione ma le tele sbatti le
magliette si male non fa prende un
pochino dai panni non d'inverno che non
si asciugano mai sicuro che non poi sono
sicuro non la scienza infusa crescendo
in realtà non impari nulla dalla vita
quello che sei a tre anni e la stessa
cosa non è danno retta di ideali hanno
gli fa male come i carcerati guglielmo
se tipo mandataria pure alla cucina non
gli auguri da un attimo si concorda ho
una spiegazione a tutto quanto questa è
della carta cioè della carta che ho
accumulato negli anni e un po di tempo e
che non sono riuscito mai a buttare
questa si chiama differenziata
ovviamente enrico questo ci siamo
mangiati noi un po di tempo fa pittura
il ricordo quel lontano giorno questo si
può pensare male e ricordi quando
abbiamo giocato al risiko night tutte le
birrette farò un po di ripoli stione
così a noi ce ne dovremmo andare se lo
so lo so lo so lo so bell degrado e
metteteci pure tu dimmelo subito da che
parte stai mai sgomberiamo libera la
cucina
dal male ok fuori allora andiamo ci sa
fare un po di affari tuoi lunata le
immagini natale
vediamo cosa c'è nella spazzatura
allevate gialle prove è pari a qui c'è
una abbuffata qualcosa di grosso tratta
della plastica lui che è un plastic free
ball mi convince ci nasconde qualcosa è
sì sì è troppa immondizia non è
possibile
come può un solo uomo produrre questa
immondizia però è un omone ha visto cosi
nascondigli di euro che cos'è una
mazzata e caravan andò nella spazzatura
nella speranza di trovare cosa togliere
il momento del fatto che sporca tutto
amo per un cappello sempre cioè quelle
cave che presentano due fate i tornelli
tutti quanti capito pulite e arriva uno
che mette il caffè su e non si sa come
vuota almeno sette tazzine sui fornelli
che poi devono pure altro io dico ma
come avete fatto
quelli sono la marca tegola comunque
subito riempito di terra noti ma si è
esplosa la caffettiera sì
mi dispiace ma sembra che abbia ragione
lui ma tanto sta al telefono con la
linea delle cose serie di faccia come è
andato via chi è affatto tipo
poi possiamo capito essere la
macchinetta del caffè calcola io che
cosa bella ma non è mai successo marco
ne esplosa ma io lo sapevo
voglio sapere io sono allibito possibile
qua pure vedrei alza un muro e c'è stata
un'esplosione
qui a trafficare ho sentito mai vista
una roba del genere c'è devo capire con
la macchinetta che problemi cha molaro
madonna che la donna dura come il marmo
mamma mia ma mi sa chi ma se non ce la
fa davide terzo tipo
la strada dell'oro così forte qui ho un
modo prendila ed inizia a girare un
impasto ecco la usiamo un dice che la
forza la meta ok passiamo a questo
abbiamo capito non è questo ma questo
deve stare sul mondo ha emesso ma questo
sta fisso se si è tolto vuol dire che se
tipo rotto questo dovrebbe stare sempre
dentro
dobbiamo capire che la macchinetta
esplora esatto ce l'ha fatta ragazzo
bravissimo eccovi di questo caso questo
il suo posto panda pure questa vedi è la
stessa cosa
[Risate]
usiamo un altra finalità per la prima
volta ha visto e ha preferito vivere che
dovrebbe stare sempre dentro quanto non
gli è messo si vede che qualcuno si era
lavato ed era rimasto sullo sgocciolato
io non ha messo un pezzo essenziale
perché non ho messo tra sempre lì
possiamo rimandare le rvm del momento in
cui guglielmo se per il tè predetto il
futuro voglio il momento del caporale
che sporca tutto o forse se già da
luciano del malaugurio
gli ho fatto 2000 è capo arida e
gianmarco cena del marinaio
buono a sapersi guardatevi il video si
mangia relatore
ma quindi esploso ovunque preso qui
escluso le finestre tutto va bene marco
per punizione milan dai noi amiamo anche
se staff attardi scusate mi lasci così
io io non ho mai ciao ciao signora
ritchie è stato il reatino è alzato
mangiami guardate che è arrivato i
nostri stagno allora vedete che sta
scalando il grasso sul piano sia
alternato a vedere cos'era si guarda
sono quasi horror e adesso ci stava
parlando insieme a sua sorella un'altra
malata di esperienze paranormali che
hanno vissuto persone come fatto da
uscite saranno raccomandate immediato in
un altro modo di vedere guardano da sole
ai denti pierfrancesco in cameretta a
guardare queste panda giulia camera
della linea guardare il the ring che
giulia guarda gli horror per addormenta
per 7 ha fatto è che dei ragazzi
praticamente la storia la leggenda di
questa bambina dice che il signorotto di
questo castello voleva nasconderla reame
perché questa bambina era nata albina e
quindi c'era la persecuzione delle
streghe c'è la persecuzione delle
streghe quindi nata albina i genitori
non volevano parlare del in giro diciamo
paura di perderla impiccata al rogo e
via dicendo che quindi facciamo le tinte
tipo con gli errori neri con erbe varie
e il colore finale risultava tipo
sull'azzurro d'aquino male ma che poi
s'è persa un certo punto giusto
lei praticamente era sorvegliata da due
guardie soltanto che la palla con cui
stava giocando le cade sotto le segrete
del castello lei la rincorre da questo
segreto e non risale più e si dice che
la notte si senta ancora di suono della
dia che facciamo nostro gioco non voglio
più parlare
mi fanno sentire le registrazioni audio
che si sente castello sta vicino ravenna
a 600 nelle registrazioni non sia potuti
entrare perché forse un po abbiamo
trovato chiuso quindi siamo andati su
magari scendendo verso la macchina io è
un'amica mi ha trovata lega accesa
aperta con la musica a palla non
succedono nel giorno delle chiese dei
déjà da conoscimenti casa sai anche poi
anche chi era di c1 la macchina aperta
se la può dimenticare la luce accesa
leggono essendo diciamo stagione avrebbe
destato veduta che si ma non la musica a
palla quindi forte c'è la prima portata
a roma è capitolata seconda pratica
mestieri da la prima quella la prima è
stata quella cagata sulla schiena
in questo pezzo se non era una cagata
certo vanno diversa e giuria mista che
mi interessa è questo e quindi è la
seconda
non mi ricordo quanto tempo fa mi
sveglio non vedo niente sento però che
c'è qualcosa di strano e praticamente
vedendo l'ambiente no no no no a roma e
vedono una sorta di filo tipo che si
muovo in aria tv inverni cello e capisco
che è sorretto da una persona invisibile
sì perché si vede un po la sagoma di una
versione visibile la terza invece
infatti loeb luciano l'avevo capito che
era una paralisi
loeb lungo noti svegliano interesse a
mora dai paradisi tutto quello che
succede con tank artico mi sveglio
niente come al solito questa volta non
c'era però una persona invisibile e
sento che qualcosa mi osserva dal basso
nel buio vedo questa figura accovacciata
che inizia a gattonare verso il mio
letto che si alza in piedi altissima con
un cappuccio rosso una felpa
la gara vede state ritorsioni
poi finita una cosa vedo che si dissolve
fuori dalla finestra appena ragazzi
sapete cosa faccio lo riprendo per 10
ore
vengo anch'io un un lungometraggio sul
catino quello che ci possa fare tutto ma
sono ancora incandescente si è in grado
scienza è successa una paletta di legno
e mezzo un pavimento noi dirigermi
lavori c'è sempre da quanta che state
usando dieci minuti e bilanci minuti
massa vedeva con quadrato la vita dieci
minuti ha fatto bene a dire una cosa io
e giulia anche se che siamo la vera
coppia collaudata guarda che abbiamo
fatto costruzioni smetti di fare due
teste sui versanti senatrice ma badate
non vedo niente ci sono aperture
chi è mezz'ora che sto costruendo il
sesso dei pompieri ma guarda che grande
opera d'arte dei nuovi personaggi sono
lussi e adesso sta facendo un samurai
carico diverse postazioni andranno messe
non avete molto per niente ma che cosa
stai dicendo
quelli hanno finito il progetto e voi il
loro progetto oltre buste diventa
quasimodo per le moto insomma nel
linguaggio quasi madama in pazza ma il
bagno giungerà vince l'inter era in
bagno vacua scansiona dove siamo pieni
di pupazzetti noi di questi dove vanno
noi tra finito 10 mila di loro il doppio
dei pezzi quindi stai dicendo che loro
sono stati scarsi non sto dicendo che no
facendo un'altra cosa subito pensiero
male no pensa quanto abbiamo lavorato
come dei pazzi
quindi un elogio a voi no è un elogio
alla follia il vostro ne avete fatto
smazza bravi ragazzi sono morti
scusate le kakà e definito che face
strano pezzi di riserva per quanto lo
distruggi cosa da fare è dare un
appuntamento a domani e finirla qui ok
bellissimo ciao